y'all spend some time in courting
recreating old movie posters right with
your kids can we look at a few
okay cool here we go okay so this is the
original poster
of audrey hepburn and breakfast at
tiffany's and i had this crazy idea that
we should
duplicate famous movie stills or posters
with my kids i don't know why i thought
of that but
they like the idea um okay yeah there
she is okay so that's matea
and that's one of our rescue kittens
that one is called creamy
orange cream school but we've been
rescued kittens during quarantine
um so i was doing her hair and makeup
and she at a certain point was like
mommy
this is not perfect i cannot do this i'm
sorry i'm sorry i cannot
this is the best i could do i'm not a
professional or makeup artist
let's see the next one this is so cool
okay this is the original james dean
yeah there's the original james dean in
rebels at a cause and
there's my son johnny my 14 year old
rebel with or without a class and we
actually showed them the movie and
johnny really loved it so
um we had the red jacket we had if you
look at the
the actual poster it's really hard to
see there but it does have a sort of
blue corrugated looking background in it
and we had this storage container on the
property so johnny stood in front of it
and looked dreamy
i mean your family is the most gorgeous
family ever the fact that they can pull
these posters off i wouldn't even
attempt it
okay here's giant great film johnny is
actually the one who's responsible for
putting all the graphics on
together with all the images that we
took and johnny's also an awesome
baseball player i just wanted to say
that
um holden who's in giant is also an
amazing baseball player
and uh giant is another james dean
classic
and it kind of fits with holdi's sort of
like
well i like to call holding my um my
burnt marshmallow he's like
hard and crispy on the outside and soft
and gooey on the inside he's an amazing
wonderful boy and they're all
very artistic they love painting drawing
photography anything to do with all this
stuff
oh i love i love and they all have their
own like individual personalities it's
so crazy even they grow up in the same
household it's it is so funny
everybody's still so different
um let's see the next one i love this
one dorothy original
that's lucia she's eight years old she's
holding another one of our rescue
kittens i think that's hufflepuff
um yeah we also have a black sort of a
black and tan brindle frenchie which may
may have looked more like toto but we
decided to use kittens
but i think they just all really love
the dress-up aspect to this
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going